la question de la libération éventuelle
de maurice papon refait débat une
polémique suscitée par les déclarations
de robert badinter lui-même qui estimait
hier que l'incarcération du plus vieux
prisonnier de france condamné pour
complicité de crimes contre l'humanité
ne vais plus de porter à cet âge là une
prise de position inattendue qui ravive
les opposants et les partisans à la
remise en liberté pour raisons
humanitaires de celui qui fut condamné à
dix ans de réclusion en 98 gilles marini
à fresnes le 22 octobre 1999 il va
passer sa première nuit de condamner
maurice papon qui purge désormais sa
peine à la prison de la santé est
devenue le détenu depuis âgées de france
trop vieux trop malade selon sa famille
et son avocat pour rester incarcéré
il est inhumain et dégradant de madiran
firme est quelqu'un y exposait à mourir
en prison quand il est dans sa 91e année
dans la plupart des pays d'europe il ya
une limite à l'exécution des peines qui
est généralement de 70 ans libéré
maurice papon après robert badinter
c'est une grande figure de la résistance
une ancienne déportée germaine tillon
qui le demandent à l'heure actuelle je
considère qu'on doit le libérer
pour des raisons d'âge d'ajouer d'âge
d'abord et aussi de compassion
nous avons le droit d'avoir pitié
d'avoir pitié des routes une compassion
qui se heurte à la douleur des enfants
de déportés robert sit ins qui lui s'est
battu 20 ans pour la tenue du procès il
ne comprend pas robert badinter
il oubliait famille il oublie de
kylie a eu quatre ya eu chaud sans mener
vieillard
parmi les nids 600 victimes qui ont été
parfois arrachés de leur lit d'hôpital
il ya eu les femmes maurice papon était
jugé pour complicité de crimes contre
l'humanité l'avocat des parties civiles
n'amenez pas qu'il puisse sortir de
prison après 14 mois même pour raisons
médicales on ne peut songer à une grâce
médicale que si véritablement est en
danger de mort mais lui qui se compare
au capitaine dreyfus il n'est pas à
cayenne il est la prison de la santé en
plein paris et tous les jours il est
suivi médicalement
donc il n'y a pas de risque à partir du
moment où les médecins considèrent que
iea en une sorte est normal pour un
homme de son âge jusqu'où peut aller
l'exécution d'une telle peine faut-il
grassi un homme coupable de crimes
contre l'humanité par deux fois déjà
jacques chirac a tranché en répondant
non